je fais le caissier se fera au café des
images à hérouville un cinéma qui fait
peau neuve
on va en parler dans quelques instants
il est né dans les années 80 justement
puisqu'on parle des années 80 tout de
suite
place à ce qui va se passer dimanche au
zénith de caen le top 50
là où ça bouge nous sommes avec marc
toesca pour vous annoncer la venue au
zénith de caen le 3 avril à 18 heures 2
top 50 évidemment vous êtes je suis marc
toesca bonjour bonsoir les flics ne vous
reconnaissez quand même beaucoup
renoncent jamais naomi campbell cauvin
c'est toute une génération
c'est formidable de réunir ces artistes
là de vous poser ses chansons qui ont
bercé toute une génération
ouais mais oh ouais des gens puisque
l'on retrouve en live des gens qui en
plus n'est jamais bon et ce qui me
touche c'est de retrouver la génération
d'ados d'il ya quelques années en
arrière aujourd'hui adultes avec les
yeux comme ça quand on est bien c'est la
ouate ici c'est formidable
justement dans ce livre que vous avez
sorti sur les années 80 il ya évidemment
une page sur le top 50 mais vous essayez
donné l'esprit des années 80 c'est pas
seulement simplement une époque de
légèreté de facilité comme on a dit
c'est plus que ça s'est passé beaucoup
de choses
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
évidemment c'est pas que la musique même
si la musique est absolument essentiel
c'est l'émergence des radios libres si
canal+
si une espèce de vent de liberté
extraordinaire mais c'est aussi la mode
c'est mugler gauthier alaïa claude
montana des gens qui révolutionne la
mode l'architecturé c'est la bdc
philippe starck et alain le grand
designer qui reste animaux un designer
qui change complètement notre notre
regard sur les choses et sur le monde
donc voilà j'ai voulu faire une espèce
de kaléïdoscope mur de berlin rossi
c'est le mur de berlin pitt sur celui-ci
dakar i c touche pas à mon pote serra
donnera ses pleins pleins de choses
donc voilà le livre c'est vraiment un
kaléidoscope de ces années assez
extraordinaire chez
évidemment votre livre c'est une pendant
du spectacle au top 50 qui va tourner un
peu partout en france
oui parce que c'est vrai que la tournée
top 50 a quelque chose de particulier
c'est que ça rend vraiment hommage à
toutes sortes de musiques le fait qu'il
aimait grèce.vers sous sa formidable
fois où c'est formidable la musique le
rock alternatif à l'époque c'est hyper
fort long métrage où l'air derrière toi
que tu y aller béru yapi gallia las
manos et des groupes qui perd important
donc je trouve qu'à une couleur musicale
qui est très belles dents dans ce
plateau top 50
et je dis pas ça parce que j'y suis
partenaire particulier quels souvenirs
vous ouvrait le bal de ce top 50 ça doit
être plus difficile la pression quoi
donc on va dire si ça marche pas ça être
de notre faute c'est sûr que ça marchera
aussi qu'un bouleversa nous peut-être
personne n'a oublié ce titre c'est
incroyable
le top 50 c'est dimanche au zénith de
caen à 18 heures salle est flou retour
donc au café des images à hérouville qui
fait peau neuve c'est un tout nouveau
lieu de convivialité mais aussi de
cinéma c'est l'heure je mange bonjour
oui passera nouveau cuisinier du café
des images
il ya une autre façon de devenir
consommer du cinéma il faut aussi
peut-être apprendre à gérer le cinéma et
la nourriture c'est ce que vous proposer
quelque chose de festif
oui tout à fait mettre en relation les
événements du cinéma tous et metteur en
scène ses réalisateurs ces acteurs qui
sont invités au café des images peuvent
descendre venir ici et aussi peut-être
avec un peu de chance faire que des
activités du récent fasse venir des gens
du cinéma égarements vous proposez quoi
comme caf alors alors c'est une carte
assez court parce que je suis seul en
cuisine du coup je suis obligé de
minimiser mon travail pour maximiser la
qualité en quelque sorte des produits
locaux et donc un menu du jour que je
fait varier le plus possible je vous
conseille c'est qui celui-là parce que
génial donné le planning la delà de
mardi se targuer du titre
le café des images qui vous propose un
événement exceptionnel jeudi à 20h30
avec la diffusion du film d'alain
cavalier la rencontre et justement ce
sera l'occasion de le rencontrer ce
réalisateur a des fidèles du café des
images juste après la diffusion de ce
film voilà vous savez presque tous les
combien de myopie je crois que ces
quatre mois quatre mois cette au moins
si je sais pas très bien
à demain